and we all know that frontline workers
have been some of the biggest heroes of
the pandemic so far
and now six of them are barbies it's
part of an initiative from mattel
honoring frontline workers during the
pandemic
and one of the barbies is a doctor from
las vegas oracle manna joins us now with
more on her
improbable journey orca
well denise dr audrey sue cruz was born
in hawaii
grew up in las vegas and graduated from
the university of nevada school of
medicine
she's a physician a mother and now a
barbie doll
it's a huge honor that i never expected
she's a barbie girl
living in a coveted world and for las
vegas physician dr audrey sue cruz
life in plastic really is fantastic
she's one of only six front line workers
around the globe getting her own
one-of-a-kind barbie doll
she got an email from mattel and barbie
executives saying they were interested
in creating a doll to look
just like her i was like what me
it was just unreal i was like are you
sure you have the right person
it's part of mattel inc's thank you
heroes program which highlights the work
of frontline workers amid kovitt 19.
according to mattel dr cruz whose
filipina joined forces with other
asian american doctors to fight racial
bias and discrimination during the
pandemic
i hope i can represent the you know
women of color women in health care
women who are
working moms just being able to
represent these people
and have them known that you know they
are seen dr
cruz says the past year has been tough
but through her work and her instagram
page
she wants her story and now her barbie
doll to inspire the younger generation
to dream big
and achieve their goals whatever skin
color you are whatever background you
come from
it's possible for you
now there's only one doll of dr cruz so
you won't be able to purchase it
but for every barbie doll that's a
doctor
nurse or paramedic sold at target five
dollars will be donated
to the first responders children's
foundation reporting live in las vegas
tonight orgomana 8 news now